le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par même skate très heureux de
travailler avec même scape si vous avez
quitté le podcast avec jean thomas jobin
vous savez que l'entretien sous la
ceinture c'est quelque chose qui nous
importe beaucoup fait même ce qu'ils
viennent de lancer le perfect package
3.0 qui se trouve être le package ultime
pour chercher beaucoup y
non non le perfect paquet 3.0 et yolande
moreau 3.0 qui est une tondeuse
électrique waterproof et qui peut faire
ça dans la douche si vous êtes si vous
êtes chez vous voulez pas mettre des
poils partout
un pilleur le skin save technologie qui
empêche de nick et les mauls pis ça
c'est extrêmement important dont il a
essayé toit pour vous êtes quelqu'un qui
aime entretenir le poil de cette région
le sait le meilleur outil là et va le
laisser ce matin pour la petite histoire
au pis ça vaut comme si ridicule comment
ça va bien ça va beaucoup mieux et que
toute ma vie il me ranger que mon clip
de barbelés mais savais que si je mens
bien pauvre et j'ai jamais utilisé un
outil aussi efficace aussi d'où aussi
pour les parties vraiment que dire de
plus clients 100% satisfait on à côté de
moi un client satisfait avec les
bascules moi aussi je l'essayé puis
honnêtement c'est vraiment la bombe
utilisée petits produits qui viennent
avec ceux dans le fond c'est comme une
espèce de petit push push tourneur qui
garde une fraîcheur qui c'est un
déodorant pour les parties que tubes et
qui à présent toute la journée
mieux peau de l'odeur ou de quoi que ce
soit désagréable qui se créent dans
cette région le ca sent tout le temps
superbe on paie dans votre perfect
package 3.0 aussi ça vient qu'une paire
de boxeurs qui respire qui sont en
matériel tech donc 100% pour le perfect
package 3.0 on a un code promo pour
d'autres qui est sans filtre en
majuscules en un mot qui donne 20% le
rabais sur le perfect package 3.0 et la
livraison gratuite donc si vous êtes un
gueux nous écoute et vous avez les mêmes
procurez-vous ce mais si vous avez un
job
puis que peut-être que son son je suis
pas comment appeler seul son bolt gay
mais pas au niveau mais vous pouvez lui
associer avec le tard les failles qui
s'en vient et fait que d'attitude merci
beaucoup à 24 juillet
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par auch la gauche lag c'est une du ciri
et microbrasseries québécoises qui nous
supportent et nous fournit et bien en
fait pendant tout le mois de décembre
ayons des spiritueux de qualité dont le
faîte agency qui est premièrement le
packaging est juste une scène
félicitations engage un gars de chlef
pour avoir fait un aussi beau branding
mais on leur donne à base de d'hibiscus
et lord john à base de pissenlit
si vous êtes dans la game de spiritueux
se nomme sinon on a aussi les deux
thoniers qui jintao l'hibiscus et gento
nectar des prêts à bord le soul et pop
côté tonic et des jeux primés langer
préfète pour toi que je voudrais acheter
ces [ __ ] dynamique incluant le bois
prendre la mli à ta bouche il aboie
incroyable il ya aussi une bière
spéciale ce temps des fêtes qui au
caramel salé m'bia au km salies c'est
parfait c'est festif et c'est dans
l'esprit de noël etc sans lien alors de
n'importe quelle fenêtre selon la
religion que vous décidez de sur
l'absolue man donkey des beaux produits
de chez h lag communiqué des causes
qu'on encourage ses bains juste un petit
mot aussi sur une autre bière qui est
super intéressant de claques qui abat
d'eau et utilise des ingrédients 10,6
c'est important les ingrédients
québécois donc on reste locale notamment
à la bière millette qui est une bière
blanche qui réutilise des mises le point
des boulangeries beta points donc
économie 360 tout est dans tout
tout est dans la tête on encourage sur
l'ancrage local merci oui énormément la
ganache lag qui est qui m'apparaît mois
ci les petites jeunes tournent ha ha je
laissais live durant la drire veulent
essayer de grève je perçois et monsieur
ollier a oublié on vous laisse là dessus
aujourd'hui le podcast est présenté par
de futurs esb embouti une entreprise
familiale québécoise qui fait des
produits en bambou des produits
écologiques des produits éthiques
c'est certifié fsc qui garantit la
gestion durable des forêts a fait pas
juste rose et toutes les forêts pour
faire des brosses à dents s'assure de la
durabilité de tout ça c'est aussi
certifie pida ça veut dire que les
produits sont sans cruauté et son vegan
finalement très important pour nous ici
au sens fait le poids très important
alors la mission de l'est fut de
futurisme bout c'est de donner aux
consommateurs une option éthiques
écologiques alors produite quotidien
comme les brosses à dents puis comme les
q-tip tour de produits qu'on utilise
régulièrement puisque aucune raison que
ce soit en plastique parle de l'ensemble
des faits est mon ph - l'ensemble des
fêtes en fait ce qu'on attend de nous
comme doom disait il ya des q-tip des
brosses à dents c'est ultra intéressant
td q-tip une fois tu te décris les
oreilles qui sifflent en plastique les
chaînes poubelle
c'est un peu navrant pour utiliser ce
mot le dit on a aussi des lingettes
démaquillantes réutilisables sur moi
pour moi ça a toujours été un non sens
de voir les lingettes démaquillantes que
moi même j'ai utilisé ou que mes
partenaires utilisant le passé je suis
tessa après chaque utilisation
on est en 2020 geispo vrai comme un néon
pompiste notre la tête dans sorte tant
que vous voulez le mais comment puis
évidemment les fameuses brosse à dents 0
st gall en bambou on a un code promo
pour vous qui est sans filtre 20 en
majuscule en un mot pour 20% of sur vos
commandes lors du check out fait
qu'encourager une entreprise d'ici qui
fait une réelle différence dans
l'environnement
donc merci beaucoup à la gagne de
futuris bambou et merci à vous de les
encourager en rien une production du
studio sfr bienvenue ou sans filtre le
podcast où on parle de ce qu'on veut
avec nos invités date site je pêche
quentin avec moi de me plante ça c'est
insultant cette semaine on est
extrêmement excité par nous inviter
d'hommes qui on aurait aujourd'hui on a
reçu les grands gagnants d'occupation de
chez nous vinça et noémie vraiment
content qu'il ait pris le temps de venir
ici
deux jours après
l'heure de vérité il le sent quand même
quatre heures ils sont encore dans juges
sont encore qui ont accepté de venir
passer deux ans à nous autres jose dos
des gens et de leur vie jose 2 c'était
un grand grand plaisir sont aussi qui au
tout aussi faim sont aussi beaux sont
tous attachants que à la télévision soit
même
mieux encore c'est vraiment un grand
plaisir on ne rit en fait
majoritairement rygdea podcasts les deux
sont puissants à leur manière son super
drôle puis on donne un petit peu de
décortiquer au des caisses qui s'est
passé leur perception de l'émission un
petit peu la bisbille il ajouté au fait
pourquoi parler de dsb qui en parlent
daudet c'était vraiment je parle de moi
et puis honnêtement après les avoir
rencontrés réellement heureux il ya
gagné mais je te retiens rien avant jean
launay tu manges avait pas beaucoup de
cheval dans partie mais même si tu as
voté pour
même si j'ai pas voté pour eux moi
j'étais heureux et très heureux
d'apprendre que c'est les gagnants puis
après les avoir rencontrées pour vrai je
suis je leur souhaite le meilleur pis je
vous souhaite à vous aussi
le meilleur c'est à dire écoutez le
podcast donc beaucoup surtout alcon et
ses lois comme numéro 1
ça paraît cool c'est parti merci d'être
là
la station on est vraiment super excité
on est comme derniers duels en fait le
lendemain de l'heure de vérité fixé
timing idéal vraiment reconnaissants
depuis la finale qui se trouvait réduit
- en fait depuis le tournage de l'heure
de vérité qui est elle une semaine
exactement une semaine et un jour
comment quel a été votre vie ça
ressemble à quoi
beaucoup d'émotion voire la famille sont
un peu partout en même temps mais on
aime soit on veut voir les gens ont vu
ces eaux là on est comme moi
effectivement on en parlera des
nouvelles personnes les années de leurs
biens les ipad là comme un genre vidéo
genre est exténué ou la confortable au
nom sur le terrain de la situation mais
tu sais ce que j'ai dit vous faire si
nos têtes on avait la radio fait il ya
un peu de fatigue accumulée depuis des
semaines des mois sans émeute un fake
ça fait que ça fait qu'hier on a dormi
mais on donne le maximum qu'on peut tout
attrait congénères qui est ce que m mais
je me rappelle quand j'étais sorti sur
pontons le ciel puis le c'est comme ça
bosse à l'infini l'excusé spelling est
ce que c'est quand même le titre il
fournit plus aux messages comme
pleinement que tu veux rejoindre mais
que tu peux comme parce qu'il ya trop de
monde me décrivent ces silhouettes par
le message était bon savez je vais
vraiment répondu ça fait chier mais on
essaye on se prend un moment le sillage
que je réponde à du monde mais c'est
impossible mais c'est beaucoup d'amour
fait et je le prends le train et je veux
y apprendre jamais si beaucoup moi ça me
donne un peu d'anxiété mais quand même
possible mais moins normal notre concept
de genre est tellement de l'éducation en
tant qu'homme 300 messages textes genre
par quel bout prendre seul round
c'est vraiment intense et saisirait
thème tombe moi pour ma part je te
rappelle ligue 1 quittée suthep a famous
sa gamme lavande il est vraiment pas le
tir après 2014 avec pour moi j'avais 12
10 m dans une journée même puis ça comme
vous voulez donc c'est beaucoup
je n'avais pas de trop koné est peter
lim limerick ouest qui arrête jamais en
ses impressions et atos et sis genre
mais on sera fixé- comédienne
félicitations à ressasser les 10 m au
tasta hui est drôle c'est lydie et
madame r eacute averti vous étiez fixés
comme que jamais le temps de quatre
chantiers il ya toujours de quoi de vous
qui arrivent partout puisque cette offre
mais on essaie vraiment à tout le monde
mais quelqu'un qu'on voulait vous
recevoir et on essaie de trouver la
façon de vous rejoindre parce que si
vous me suivez pas serein 50 et que mon
message n'est pas tombé d'accord aux
amis caché là c'est sûr ça va tomber
dans comme autres les chances que vous
tombiez sur mon message important comme
limite le même si c'est moi j'ai très
vite rit parce que m pourquoi ce temps
que fait que ça mais comme ceux qui ont
des sujets phares aider ceux qui sont
comme quand plus d'abonnés fixe pour ce
jeu
c'est ce que vous et moi des traités par
exemple jeté d'ittihadia notamment
beauvue prévu mais merci ça a été
mouvementée mais je pense qu'on a bien
fait mais c est la première étoile
mais ça fait du bien mais j'ai pris mon
temps le pauvre vu là un peu mieux
j'agis pour un moment c'est le sétois
live le moment de répondre me demander
mes questions sur kbc ça a été coupée
mais y ont vraiment mis tout qu'est ce
que j'ai dit récemment espié a bavé avec
nous j'ai regardé tout qu'est ce que je
disais ok je suis inutile mais tient pas
quelque chose de commun et on coupe le
jet de la douche et pas trop quoi
ouvriers sabine et east poutine mais ça
fait du bien de s'exprimer par rapport à
l'association petit tu le fais au dépent
la fin c'est tout bois les émissions les
avait pas vus t en ville vous avez
écouté dans le fond avec les deux autres
co finalistes dont les finalistes
vraiment ce test expérience là c'est pas
toujours facile
j'imagine baisse a quand même bien été
parce qu'on est quand même tout des
personnes qui s'entendait vraiment bien
si dray fait que on l'a quand même des
cubes bien et c'est sûr que quand que
sont arrivés au milieu de la saison
c'est plus difficile ses avocats qui est
qui et c'est comme cela ça c'est paris
c'est comme ça c'est un peu plus
difficile
puis vous moyens peu d'un show
lechardeur parce que je vois tellement
tout match pour moi mais ça était là il
me met des radars mais pas face à savoir
attali puisse avoir des vraies émotions
parce que je tire vite si oui c'est
clair ouais c'est bon pour un sujet qui
est lui même moi je pensais pas que ça
allait atteindre ce projet de gens de
regarder et soul
je pensais pas que c'est moi je ne se
fâche et même pas
connectez vous je peux servir toute la
saison je cible avait coûté si vous avez
vous géré activement à canal grille ce
qui arrivait mais la voir se piler
malheureusement l'acharnement qui
arrivait de chekka maquillage plus
capable je me sens comme énerver un peu
mais je suis avec les autres ça se
passait bien c'est sûr que comme vous
avez vu aussi t on est un peu déçu de
poste ce qui n'est pas ça c'est du temps
d'écran qui avait pitié je dis moi ce
que je dirais expliquer ces secteurs eau
d amiens et que tu ta saison puis les
autres a pris le parti revient souvent
sur le fait que tu as un certain point
ton copie et former ses esprits on le
sait comme il veut le voir vivant
quelque chose qui m'a un peu les yeux
[ __ ] gt1 mais on se mit nuageuse et je
pense que mon agent et moi on fait le
tour fait que moi je leur ai expliqué ce
geste par qui je sais pas quand ils
s'occupent de ça qu'ils sont conscients
de ce mets vraiment réellement moins vu
que vous que jamie stacy ou que dur à
dire que j'ai pas trouvé tant souhaité
qu'on les voyait quand même s'ils ont eu
des bons moments pis pour elles y ont
vraiment bien portant sur l'utile public
qui les a marqués je pensais juste que
d'autres l'ont vécue fait qu'il ya des
partis que eux n'ont pas vu de leur
début qu'ils auraient aimé voir pour
comme sans rappeler tous les regards des
francos or c'est comme ça que nous
entamons tbt qu'annonce pas là qu'on
s'embrasse et la première fois c'était
le cas soit examiné
nous on s'est tellement boîtier vous
avez l'air tellement plus fermé mais
c'est sûr que karim est plus nouveau
prêté il y avait beaucoup de chichi
métis leur mac tu vois tu du hamas et
ceux qui vont le mieux c'est sûr ça
c'est pas il m est là ça m'aurait dit
ben moi j'avais un super bon moment mais
quand drian qui aurait mis le voir c'est
normal mais
et il a chanté pas la tricherie si la
grosse à fin de la saison avec 5 6 4
ce match je fais moi je n'ai pas surpris
puis je dire c'est qu'elles ont dit
aussi vu plus que d'un show en terme de
temps peut-être mais à terme de moments
des coupes cause tous minutes puis
concert mais c'est pour ces moments là
on entre dans le fond c'est une question
il faut que tu vois ça mais tant que tu
recules un peu il faut que tu vois
surtout d'un point de vue qui ont une
histoire à raconter les picards ton
histoire est terminée il n'y a plus rien
après les tirs
l'histoire est finie on s'aime c'est bon
on attend la fin si steed attié vous
alliez au moins deux moteurs de comme
étant pas en opposition avec charles est
un petit tout ce qui vous qui vous
pourrez pousser à chaque fois le tir en
devenir un petit peu dans trame
narrative puis je reste toujours une
question avec eux qui me vient en tête
le tout avec huit att en finale me
semble rejoindre les camps avec adamo
pier-alexandre pis andric jugé l'expert
des fous de ce htc serait jamais passé
dans chaque amincie dessin final mais
chez comme 90% oui de sources
annonçaient que éprouvé c'est comme ça
que tu gagnes occupation
les favoris via l'école a reçu ses
matches avec la plus proche pour une
mairie s'est prononcé qu est-ce qui
était en pointe qu'un kidimath ont le
savoir ce qui va se passer et puis le ca
bah oui puis non c'est ça qu'il ya des
fois ça change et le thé la prod ils ont
quand même plus de tout et c'est un
autre chat bouquet on pense mais disait
en battant et sa détermination des faits
ou gogh ou peu importe que c'était petit
soir c'était second film est en fait une
légende
jusque là ça fait jaser puis moi j'ai la
pêche parce qu'on le voit pas mais moi
j'ai dit moi j'ai dit et ce afin qu'ils
étaient un peu de chic ex touristique
s'est amené pas 5,15 d'ado dès qu'ils
ont passée inaperçue aux gens qui vont
un peu moins de la semaine cinq stades
de thé ces cinq candidats qui ont marqué
la saison fait célèbre au début je me
demandais si coûts qui s'en viennent
chercher ici tu es au début ce test est
comme un peu difficile à gérer mais je
pense que les choses sont bien faites
qui ont de plus réalisé assez assez vite
mais non c'est s'arrêter à deux bonnes
semaines les canaris se situe j'arrive
chaud
c'est vraiment une personne qui disait à
quel point qu'elle n'avait jamais écouté
aude et puis je vais je la crois 100%
même qu'elle dit qu'elle avait été
approchée pour faire le show et métier
je pense que toutes les autres qui ont
fait l'émission est l'anti l'ol à lui
coûtait peau mais elle savait quand même
c'était quoi c'est tout le monde sait qu
audi au québec et where d'abord no grave
je sais pas quel âge vous avez précisé
moi j'ai trois générations jamais avoir
parlé d'eux mêmes et antoine ont émis de
l'écouté qu'est ce qui te pousse à y
aller dans le fond mais samassa l'enfant
parce que tu vois la ddt jeter comme le
genre de réponse écrite est vraiment
intéressant puisque mon nom je suis
pressé d'y aller je vois pas et mes amis
rencontrés les ghosts comme dans le coin
je parlerai pas été comme souvent jamais
en voiture mais je suis obligé les dans
le faux départ de la cale terme ans au
début mais je t'ai pas si vide à malte
et je parle à tout le monde bouge peu
comme moi on parle à toutes les golfs
damas à me tirer dans le pied mais j'ai
continué ex parce qu'il y avait
d'ailleurs jusqu'au prix que j'ai eu
quelques choisir mais ça me rend fou
c'est à juste comme fait savoir qu'il
faut ziva par l'augmentation de quoi
parader comme le baiia les soiffards de
quoi une femme doit pas prendre la
parole et puis c'est bon comme ça lui
fait que c'est bon ribéry et l'histoire
très vite je valide avant tout le québec
a le sentiment d'avoir grandi puis
d'avoir appris surtout beaucoup pendant
le temps que le west utilisateurs y
auriez le sujet à dubaï fraude est
prouvée oui je capable de plus
m'exprimer mais tu me vois un peu dans
saison le thé ça avance un peu plus
puisque sommes plus à l'aise d'être moi
même aussi puis et aux moindres est que
les carmes c'est juste qu'un beau je
m'en fous un peu je veux juste être moi
mais ça me rend fou c'est mesut avec lui
sont un peu comme oreiller on faisait
livrer un peu puis remaniée mais moi je
gisais oublié tes beaux défis son petit
jard oublier karim et moi ma niche comme
méthode et phonique y attachant depuis
toujours la fille plati qui parle pour
rien disait qu'est ce que je pensais
mais je restais comme moi tu joues pas
les genres deux personnes qui créent
ensemble c'est ça fait pendant faut donc
mais je suis vraiment naïf et c'est ce
qui était drôle et films qui racontent
n'importe quoi lui les gunners mais ceux
qui demain cette fois c'est passé pour
filmer les fans dormi ensemble on se
retrouve pourquoi mais les dieux fait
ensemble
merci si on avait déjà donné le contenu
mais pourquoi pas plus c'est notre
soirée étions au filet le cndd sont
évidemment plus celle de la soirée de ce
qu'on avait notre époque et services on
voulait conclure sud et benalia mais
c'était pas possible piège sept jours
blacks c'est parce que joe black black
black bénévoles toujours le petit 1 et
nous nous le handicap
je sais pas si c'était dur blacks sont
normands n'avaient gioia mais jude et
les yeux bleus ce match est un nouveau
jeu que ça va être dur aux blacks ce
fonctionnaire mais il savait joe pesci
et nous y opposer qui est elle une
nounou des voyages pilet c'est
évidemment on ne fait pas les dents des
chambres ont fait trop souffrir wade
veut y mettre des textes s'ils portent
faite le on est dans la chambre
lytro tient juste pour recommander à ce
prix puis évidemment on veut chercher un
beau de jouer moins on la laisse dans
champion remonte exactement faible et
moins étudiée mourront pilleurs
jeudi un mouvement apporte chaque fois
comme si je m'étais infiltrés j'ai volé
takhar pis je tâche en vérité il m'ouvre
la porte s'ouvre jouvin jean blanchard
que je fais quand même chine entraîneur
j comme j'y voyais incartade où logent
les marianne est comme non non non non
je le connais un peu paniqué votre aux
ventes de choix de finalement fait que
les flamands jo iconia porte je fais
comment nous inquiète des fêtes le jeudi
j'ouvre la porte puis je me cache la
porte et me laisse devant la nounou
c'est ce qui fait qu'elle est le seul la
chambre mais comme beaucoup trop loin
pour avoir la porte d'où djoudi a
commencé la partie loin des canons
d'argent les chipeaux badege abeilles
n'ont elles jamais pauvre et a paniqué
je voyais l'addition visant ses bons
riffs de matam voyant pour dieu qui dans
chambre capoté mais devrait cependant
pas ça on le sait
non mais parce que johnny était vraiment
dû le petit gars viennent chaque année
quand c'est fait chicaner une fois parce
qu'en cas chez nos micros parce qu'on
voulait qu'aucune des cochonneries ou
choquer ses défauts je suis pas fou
j'avais les micros sont ultra susan
elliott une chance d y entend de tout
paris les ans nous ont été commis on se
farcit on était les prix génie qui passe
à taches éparpillées dans le parti qu'un
qu'un l eau à are venait d'avoir truqué
les trucs sur youtube le micro qu'il
faudrait pas que la personne
quand même assez de moments of mike
hoffman
si maintenant dans des villes ou des
enfants comme ceux que vous partiez en
activité ou des moments mais je dirais
qu'un des plus grands moments qu'on a eu
vraiment africaine mais à me tourner
pour le web car je te dirais que c'est
quasiment 90% pour cadenasser sur ses
reins qui me viennent vraiment en tête
et aux bras par apax avait déjà émis
deux autres titres déjà émis à lire tout
le fait que ça va vite fait qu'énoncer
ça on est quand même urgent de 509
béatifique c'était cool mais on respecte
vraiment des cons était bon pli nous
nous le dise tout le monde antique ont
été bons avec le baseball le jeu musical
est au coeur de notre taille appelés
face aux baisses bornes et moi ce qui
m'avait dit c'est plus tu respecte les
règles plus on t'enlève exact fixé
khanjar hacker on parle pas de la guerre
mon papa de la gameplay
ils font craquer mais si vous parlez pas
de la game est parlé de ce que vous
voulez c'est lieberman a exactement son
adresse connaît des couleurs vives et
les vieux cheapos chemins se séparent
ça n'a pas l'air
on a été chanceux parce que nous ce
n'est pas tant les moments on a beau
dire moi ça me fait qu'on connait c'est
tout
de là ils ont tellement on arrive il est
parti pour des causes utiles gens avec
les autres tout le monde dénonce quand
on freine depuis longtemps qu'un ouais
c'est clair c'est toi parce que tu avais
quand sa maison mixtes c'est à tant pis
pour vous cest investi davantage les
timides développer une relation dans le
fond je vois dix minutes par semaine ou
deux mais c'est fou tu sais pas ce que
je faisais le monde chez les médecins
bretons je pense un peu à la règle du
fameux on veut point coupe de maisons
médicales
mais si je dis ça s'est fait de même
sans pitié je dirais même des dames et
on mixe une chose mais c'est le fait
d'être à audi au site est aussi sa audi
jeudi deux pas de travail tête à 37 ans
pour désactiver sigean t24 littéralement
24h 24 avec la personne sur des 24
heures sur 24 dès que la personne
souhaitée 0 heures sur vingt quatre
d'entre eux deux ils exactement
affectées pourrait avec un avantage
définitivement figé moi j'étais chanceux
que les gunners peuvent sortir plus tôt
parce que je pense que quelqu'un est
sortie du rouge à la maison mixer au
paintball ça a peut être moins les
yankees ont été rapides mais par nous
moi je m'attendais à ce que ce soit
moins que la main n'ont fait tant mieux
mais moi les filles m'ont pas un défi
merci d'ailleurs
et on ferme on est au défi donc des
comme tout le monde
c'était au lieu de triper sur la
personne que tu penses que l'hôte ali en
a la brillante imminent par semaine le
vous connaissez pour les scénarios il
vous sortez de là puis vous avez déjà
habité ensemble n'ont aucune mauvaise
surprise les amarres si je sais ce qui
se fait pas longtemps qu'on est dans la
vraie vie mais ai je dit c'est je
regarde la fille même she came qu'un
match c'est comme un conte pour espagne
et je tiens à me tape sénat quand elle
est son linge traîné mais ça parce que
c'est drôle c'est pâtissent pas méchant
c'est ici rien mon idée personnelle très
loyal je fais confiance à lille pour sa
série ce proche de son but qui fait que
je vois qui aucun il ya aucun gros
élément déclencheur qui pourraient
survenir à ce que jusqu'à date
c'est beau mais que tu dis ouais pour la
neige qui traîne ça parle d'un couple
d'amis
les tests les fameux tests mais jamais
avec les couverts découvertes à côté
mais c'est plus que je mange mal en plus
c'est que je laisse traîner je mange du
crush l'élu maria déjà dit qu'il y avait
là la face du moulin fouet
je laissais le plastique sur le multi je
le sais pas si je me souviens avec un
jour de plastique et 9,6 en place et
pardessus pluie a découvert qu ont fêté
jeudi double couvercle toof le plastique
taille à l'ouvré voulez vous lui a tant
déçu
c'est pas tout le monde qui fait ce mais
je sais pas c'est pas une pratique
courante
ce que j'ai appris parce que moi aussi
moi je suis comme toi je moi j'enlève le
plastique au complet du pur d'humus
fontaine santé moi j'avais beaucoup plus
souvent qu'autrement quand je mange du
bus en compagnie de personnes notamment
injuste réservé hier soi ou est-ce que
j'ai passé à l'affection de faire le
plastique est pas un but du polonais pas
plus tard qu'il ya des villages très
calme je me grattais un peu amer est ce
que je me laisse pourtant way londres
heathrow la place étaient craquelés mais
comme je l'espère
la place qui est aussi le lieu de deux
suffit quand tu rentres sur les bleus
comme 2,4 je laisse tout aussi et on va
essayer d un fonds de verdun peine de
les hommes à huy que je racontais nous
on n'avait qu'à midi jean des fichiers
tiff que j'étudie pichet pour huit jours
mais j'ai finalement transformée en
pochette au fait que je mettais de l'eau
du robinet puis j'aime et en afrique
depuis que sa fraîche fait lui à
l'arrivée en mixte le jeu là vous ces
mouches dans le salon puis je la vois au
loin la cuisine tient à boucler pipi les
richesses a donné que quatre sujets en
pis et le shaker qu'on recevait caen
frappe sèche et qu' ils installent après
sam et ont empêché fait naturellement
tu remplis elle arrive dans la maison
mx2 open les pêcheurs remplissons chez
cubjac chez violents entre les chemins
je la vois le lait rempli la fiche du
jeu la coche que mais jusqu'à ce qu'on
la fait comme l'a fait qu'est ce qu'ils
risquent qu'il ya des facteurs font les
pichets ya les rapides seules où je
serai content comme hachette
ce à quoi diffuser le rap c'est ça le
regarde déjà tu gagnes la tchèque a tout
le temps quelqu'un j'ai regardé les
documents qui faisaient grimper sans
frais pour chaque compte
mais si jamais elle faisait pas de juste
cette pièce débute enfin
je suis vraiment désolé et je sais c'est
tellement drôle c'est justement là pour
ceux qui jouent sans guillemets village
et de l'inde aux dirigeants de la
finance au vu de la tension et cela m'a
souri aux finalistes et jenson
championnats mondiaux de genre baseball
la journée du life
ouais ouais t'as que cette journée qui
est tellement longue a tellement aucun
sens mais lui sait pas qui c'est mais
cinq thèmes comme terry tout à easy go
et le me parle pas dans l'autobus pour
aller fna ça me tue
c'est sûr qu'on était pas reposer mais
ils viennent même un peu craqué il
permet de faire quelque chose d'aussi
ton takagi plomb ont lancé le losc a pas
même il ne parlait pas d'enfants mais si
joseph guéguen un background compétitive
j'ai compris tient vraiment haut niveau
fait pour moi quand je cache mon
investissement quelque chose une
compétition justement je vole une pige
pas que je veux gagner à tout prix oui
mais je ne suis pas un mauvais perdant
mais mais quand même quelque chose que
je réussis pas je tombe mal puisque je
me pose des questions comme qu'est ce
qui fait que je les pauvres c'est comme
commun que je peux arriver à réussir
fait l'achat de l'or soprema moi je suis
gaucher la vie fait clemi financier de
la droite mouvement non habitués à lire
ça marche mais elles avaient moins de 8
ans qui rythment on allait jusqu'à
demain le projet tamarind cefic fallait
fallait trouver un moyen de la voie
puisque pour ce que je parlais plus
parce que je vais tomber dans mon mode
focus je trouve le moyen de la voie puis
le plus joli mais la journée de la
finale m'a littéralement guide il était
comme pauvres est revu d'amour gay monde
absolu je m'imaginais que j'allais
littéralement dans ce tournoi puis genre
ces jeunes isolés mais toutes les
personnes devant moi cette journée le
rapport c'était comme des adversaires
mais aussi car oui ou non c'était pas
méchant c'est juste que j'étais vraiment
le juste la faim dans un autobus pense
je me sens vraiment un feeling dans un
tournoi vraiment besoin mais c'est drôle
tu dis ça parce que carl j avais
enveloppe l'émeute on lui disait expo
nous faut nous prévenir
drôle dont on semble plutôt c'était
peut-être de gagner mais jusque là tu
étais rendu le mettons ces pôles mais
passe maintenant les autres on s'y
tromper qu'on leur demande maintenant
les trois co finalistes long après avoir
vu les émissions on était tout le monde
ensemble on a soupé puis on a fait c'est
moi qui t'ai cygan puis tout le monde
était d'accord là dessus tout le monde
était comme catégorique qu'après les
émissions et ont gagné
nous ce qu'on n'avait pas vu passer
c'était les réseaux sociaux qu'est ce
qui s'était passé ces réseaux sociaux
puis la traîne de réseaux sociaux
c'était quoi
mais vous êtes en interne c'était quoi
le feeling et c'est ça qui est comme toi
on avait vu les réseaux sociaux c'est
sûr qu'on avait vu les chopines tombe tu
es fier de nous se trouvait vraiment que
ont ni d'envié vip c'est quand même un
final si tu regardes tu sais pas comment
mais menez genre je pense maintenant à
vis de personnages ont un parc
mais ce sont les dons étaient confiants
mais l'heure de dire on va le gagner et
ça c'est drôle et c'est comme un
couperet gagner en plus alors les
éditions vous regardiez maton et oui
c'est vraiment simple c'est jeudi
même à la fin c'est visuellement on
avait vu show complet puis encore le
jetez pas convaincu parce que dis-je tas
d'idées 2 en coupe qui c'est mais
vraiment on était trop court qui
s'aiment vraiment mais différemment fait
que combative public que s'attache à
quai comme deux des personnages drôles
d'oiseaux personnes sont vraiment comme
gaga puis nous qui étaient comme les
deux plaintes les 2 e
on savait potes c'est qu'on savait pas
qu est-ce qui est publiquement c'est non
plus tu es
québec td voix ils peuvent être comme
ses investissements sauf si jamais et
ses facultés spéciales comme feeling
donc tes potes en convient topic est ce
que vous pensez que fait pencher la
balance pour vous mettons en voir un peu
vu les autres saisons doute et je pense
pas ta saison que je pense que c'est
vraiment des mots qui voient les choses
de l'été même arrivé avec sa stratégie
tu parles est ok mais moi en étant un
gros fardeau déjà vu adam ou pharyngées
est russophone
puis je m'attache à ça je trouve que ça
me représenter parce que dans ma nature
je suis comme ça puis il ya plein de
moments qu'on voit pas caméra métier
quand on est accro des extrêmes et on
les jetait toujours la première fois par
la cadence été jetés à la fft naturel
pour moi
le camion avait écouté les choses je
suis pas si tous les autres gueules
c'est avec tu fais erreur une faute on
n'avait aucune idée
on est à raison des finalistes ont
écouté choc non voix des mots qui
parlent ou cameron à chaque émission
bien même je faisais ça c'est qu'est ce
qui est vrai c'est que silvio légaux et
sa veste et qui fait quoi les goyas les
paris c'était leur running à la caméra
qui donne exactement votre confié à
séduit au fait que le seuil avait-on pas
caché son premier fringe est installée
dans la cave où il ya quelqu'un derrière
la science est accablant on a vu
quelques segments mais je pense
quasiment chaque jour dans la maison
mais que je parle a dit l'américain
fallait que je trouve un nom très
inquiète et je sais pas je n'ai pas
trouvé non trop conventionnel fait que
j'étais site viège pas que ça faisait un
peu exotique mais pour revenir vraiment
là converser avec les discussions
initiales qui sont en tête à toulouse
c'est un fait c'est quoi qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'à des la
steppe
oui c'est ça qu'est ce que la première
permettant pas à me la mets moi je pense
juste que on était un coupe évidemment
été retardé
je pense que vous ne voyez pas amender
les termes en les mêmes deux macaques à
zéro j'ai repris je pense qu'on a vu
toutes nos facettes de nos personnalités
dans l'aventuré autant nous contenir
autant du côté amoureux autant de côté
plus difficile avec la tricherie était
mon moi je veux un peu plus en mode
défensif puisque gemini point ça à table
est là on a vu son côté un peu plus soft
et on a juste vu toutes nos facettes de
nos personnalités
je pense que c'est sur le monde a aimé
en tout cas j'espère j'ose croire que
c'est ce biais là cela me semble une
bonne analyse
c'est vrai que vous avez eu beaucoup de
gens les péripéties le type de
revirements qu'ils avaient comme fait
face à l'adversité et on a fait preuve
de résilience se serait fait qu'amener
vous étiez commandes argileux you tube
kids out
c'est ce qu après ce pic et qu'est-ce
que vous quittez la dans le temps
c'était comme vous été un peu victime
d'une injustice dans le fond ce que le
monde sa saga vous gagner la sympathie
des gens avec ça mais je pense que le
monde sont intéressés à vous recommander
les genres les plus récents
je pense que on reprend ce scénario le
si moi j'arrive la soirée que je
l'appelle tablait par exemple
puis j'en vois chez tout le monde pas
mal sourit je peux ça se passe
de même le dirigeant fo qm n est pas
vrai
fâché parce que je l'avais mal j'avais
mal transmise et mes émotions je peux
m'asseoir le monde aime moins tripes et
je pense que le monde ont juste apprécié
le fait que j'ai comme quand même bien
géré cette situation le puits elle aussi
d'ailleurs encore chaud mais je pense
que c'était aussi par là l'espèce de
fait que votre histoire continue est
juste trop long les pigeons c'est aussi
d'avoir à calgary c'est pas mal le
dernier voyage
ouais d'avant le dernier voyage toujours
payer un seul doigt c'est comme des
toupies qui a faim dans le fond le thé
parce que les images de voyage sur le
temps ultra beau être positif type le
souvenir que mon nom là le dernier
souvenir qu'elles m'ont annoncé comme
crime c'était magique tout le monde vote
pas pour ce que s'est passé semaine 2 au
sitv que les deux autres coupes sont
comme parti plus vite à final et comme
que des missions que son pilote qui on
vous voit qu'ils mangent et son oncle la
fin on était souvent india et c'était
c'est bon vous avez été miné tout ça
vous donne un avantage métier on sait
pas éliminer comme ça on a envoyé nos
amis en finale mais rendu le c'est un
avantage
et oui puis non c'était comme pas honte
et hull trop fatigué aussi nous
déterminerons tecomah qui s'ébroue six
fois zaraki dans les mettons les
dernières semaines le je sais pas si
vous ça vous a fait ça mais moi et
dernière semaine je serais retourné chez
nous marseille n'a pas final j'aurais
été vains car le puits a pas d'être si
je n'y a pas du tout un mode capable de
l' aventure je pourrais retourner chez
nous l'eau depuis fin juin
c'était moi ce même de nouvelles pour
tous
les autres 9 8 heures la vue mais on l'a
vu à paniquer vous étiez toutes plus
improbables
le type le qualifier in apps mais ça
semblait mettons l'année à ph le genre
montrer qu'ils en attendent complètement
viré foot perche est revenue genre
dépression presqu'île tgfc dessus
c'était cool et au mental du monde me
tombe à la fin je te dis que moi puis
visons c'est quand même vraiment positif
parce qu'on se dit qu'on est vraiment
chanceux tchèque la kfw petit on sait
qui on sort de l'eau rien à faire
clairement le comme on est logés nourris
ont nos amis qui confine à la chaux de
tv ou genre d'avis c'est dans le fond
tout genre charlie pourra rien toute
façon ça ça arrive moi qui ai fixé
supplie jamie foxx est ici sont vraiment
les d'backs fait que d'autres et il
était dans un bon style of mind je pense
que android car il était un peu plus
aboutie et mais je pense parce que
d'autres étaient visés sont en amour on
veut juste là vivent ses collègues aussi
et mais je pense qu'après ils ont rasé
la fin le titre c'est sûr que c'était
plus long les exclus attend la finale
c'est long surtout pas mais je pense les
autres l'ont pris plus dur que nous
aimer ce nom pourrait enfin on était
quand même vraiment l'hôte windows phone
ouais c'est ça c'est xavier pas l'air
d'avoir vraiment toxicité le témoin ce
qui m'a dirigé jusque jusqu'au fond du
baril c'était une personne extrêmement
toxiques dans l'aventuré le tiff ex
aequo à chaque jour il y avait une
nouvelle chute le type c'est toujours
une nouvelle fuite fallait se battre car
c'est plus pour comme défendre nos
intérêts s'est fixé trois chars de l'opt
et brûlé la politesse aux milliers de la
vente ok je te brûler ma ps3
il est plus infinie
belga puis on sent la députée on
s'entendait bien pour de jeter un parce
que verlan final ces gens aiment
vraiment qui fait que c'était l'fun la
fin avant tout avoir bien été fait qu'on
était à bout tu sois que oui on est vers
d'état mais dans ce sommet en maintenant
des cas et si audard coville est filmé
dans le fait que ça soit le fait que
c'est au québec le show pensez vous que
sa vaste expérience - nice où vous
voudrez c'était 100% a bâti la vérité on
se cache le pôle jeux en relief un
safari à au milieu de l'afrique du sud
où je sais pas moi aller cueillir des
pommes mais je trouve que moi je trouve
ça le fun car même parce que d'un mois
personnel arrive tous les jours j'aurai
jamais pris le temps de lancer seul
simon qui fait que je peux je pense à
nous est permis de le faire de belle
manière à des coûts des billets date
site mais ça risque et la big three je
pense que montréal mais souhaite au
brésil pays bas je suis doux la
production aussi tâté repas les autres
le rendu est faible et on dix semaines
huit semaines neuf le quai mais comment
sa famille le week-end on veut pas les
seuls si c'est plus de l'eau pour le
titre je peux moi je suis quelqu'un qui
a besoin elle n'a du soleil puis de la
belle elle avait température le life et
non à 4h30 ça me fait pas une caméra
c'est sur ce balcon il fait moins de
rythme pas envie le fait que ça change
un peu l'atmosphère
je pense que ce niveau là c'est plus
difficile surtout pour les week-ends
comme que je dis petit week-end n'en est
rien afin non sortis sur le balcon
ça devenait le style années passées en
afrique je pense qu'ils avaient le droit
de faire des promesses qu'ils voulaient
anguilles mes écrits ça change de la
guinée mentalement c'est aussi mais je
trouve qu'à rodez on n'était que ça car
pour thomas lüthi
ouais c'est un personnage quelqu'un joue
un peu plus juste et qui met dans le
fond c'est à dire tu as à od toutes et
toutes les émotions sont des vraies
émotions métier même si le monde qui
l'écouteront chambre c'est exagéré ou
qui trippent de même parce qu'en faire
de l'escaladé dans un bâtiment
désaffecté
c'est comme non mais c'est autant
christine bivort tout deviendra plus et
après si ça te met en perspective la
perception des affaires qui entourent
but d'amener l'équipe ça va faire du 4
août
on avait hâte le talent camping de
surville hinson des axes utc le celle
que j'aurais préféré que delà de mon
oeil de la personne qui peut-être pas
dormi dans une pub mais sa valeur si je
pensais que j'allais mourir bêtement je
suis heureux sur une envie mais ça
s'abîme et l'épique finale ce n'est pas
un genre il voudrait pas au milieu avec
un couteau
mais bon je me suis surpris puis sa
venue est une de mes activités préférées
est vrai que je t'ai rien à sauver mon
ne pas devenir fou
vous avez pas dormir je suis en mode
dans le monde
est ce que vous avez à faire quand vous
avez fini venez nous dire aïe
surprise surprise après deux ans au
economics peu importe les enfants à des
termes de genre ça commence avec le
temps que ça finisse le hockey et le go
le vtt d'amener vers nous on pense qu'on
doit vraiment le match et partant on
dort le après la vie' tout le monde
ensemble et christine johnson les genres
et les gens adorent ce genre quoi on est
au près de cassis avec menaçant je
voulais pas de l'amour
mais qu'allait laisse tout winnipeg
on va soit 9,8 mais ça tout va bien la
ram est resté les jobros par et de
gentils on dit clairement que pep s est
laissée aux riez henriette l'a pas dit
on trouvait ça m'a fait drôle affecté
c'est georges les autres saviez mais
c'est un moment très drôle c'est quand
même un petit vraiment dormir ici parce
que nous ont-ils dans sa loge était
comme moi ces gens manu de la mort on
peut tout comme reste ici mais
finalement c'était bien trop froid je
pense que le poster mais c'était quand
même assez drôle puis je pense pour ce
qui a été produit
oui je sais la partie qui le monde
connaisse pas downing qui parce que dans
le fond aux autres avant de rentrer
c'est que savez vous avez fini fait que
s'ils savaient que vous avez fini ce
parce qu'écouter je fais donc ça finisse
le on était au large puis en plus
ensemble depuis le soudan penser que la
caméra était mort type le lendemain
matin on fait nos entrevues blessés
cambi garçon s'est endormi la fin et
avait un micro en dessous de votre lit
la fille qui faisait le sont parce que
la caméra était réellement mort tu
gagnes pas tu vas y ma fille faisait
leçon a dit ça nous regarde a fait
détonner dans le x dans ma vie du fait
que inquiétez vous pas pour ce que j'en
sais la bravade ce que j'avais quelqu'un
ça fait sept mois à la maison des gars
fort moi je n'ai pas non mais t'es avec
des pots cassés on ne veut pas de filmer
au complet tokyo mais dans le sous sol
ouais c'est la prod la pauvre l'ipo
achever ce qu'ils écoutent tous qu'une
gaffe qui font face à john c'est fou je
peux comprendre que met-on type à ce que
ces archives bstu ceux qui nous écoutent
ils doivent remplir dans le fond
quasiment mot pour mot qu'est ce qui se
dit qu'est ce qui se passe pour qu'après
ce soit facile de repérer les
conversations pu faire le montage métier
la prod le ti sont tellement proches de
vous plus clément que je peux comprendre
qu'ils mettront le cap jay a pété une
coche à carling caustique à celle
récoltée bouquin haïti nous ont conduit
ce dans le confort de la foi de ses
confrères au foyer c'est qu'en voyant
tous assortis oui l'oeil était bourgogne
homme et une femme qui est exagéré comme
réaction puisque c'est grossier mais je
peux comprendre qu'elle se mettant
quelqu'un qui bougonne non-stop tout le
temps pendant genre une semaine deux
semaines
camani le moral la preuve d'efforts
c'est l'écouté amman et c'est ce qu'ils
meurent à la preuve
c'est ouf je parle mais il est décidé à
tout les cantons des petits commentaires
et arrêter de charlie rose en temps si
on avait tous nos aînés nous voir tout
autant games on vous attend à 20,84
arrêté j'allais parce que toutes les
ententes tout à fait que c'est sûr que
ça peut être difficile cette entente
autant attendre et c'est sa manière de
jouer d'autres s'ils comprennent que
voter la réalité d'un candidat et par là
même que d'avoir accès à son sel chez
eux dans une maison coupé tout contact
ces stocks pour virer fou un peu fait
c'est normal qu'il y ait un peu le tempo
la rue c'est pas naturel comme comme
situation d'alors se sont arrêtés moi je
m'attends mois à la maca je les voyais
tu sais ce que des votes avaient joli
petit mais à chaque fois que j'ai
justement à une phase plus négative mais
je me rue mme josette c'est quand même
été chanceux de tisser sa carrière je
peux voir du monde petit peut être avec
des gens qui tiennent des amis faire des
parts et même c'est pas tant que ça
c'est au moins mieux que la personne qui
est chez eurapharma chez du télétravail
c'est vraiment cela que moi je me chaque
fois que justement le chômage un mode un
peu plus si négatif jeudi le juge mère
disait quand même comment maintenir est
pas grosse cloche promène celle à chaque
lundi à chaque jeudi les cinq assiette a
déniaisé le cqn jo et puis les grecs
chara après elles n'ont cessé
j'imagine que oui car même d'arriver
pilote est habitué des katibate et
chaumes jean la soutenait groupe laisser
comme ça lui plaît au monde
au québec c'est assez prudemment droit
de se rassembler le facteur c mais
qu'est-ce que m'étant a aussi proche de
soi que la fin du dic c'est sûr ça voilà
répondre changé au fil du temps mais
qu'est ce que vous allez retenir le plus
c'est quoi le highlight s'y coller c'est
quoi les choses que vous devez retenir
les plus de ce ça peut être un concept
ça peut être un événement comme tel même
on pourrait reprendre si pencherait
passivité comme ce mois-ci ramallah mais
le feeling nous n'avons pas arrêté le
soir le petit réveil pts 6 ce que tu as
fait cette preview licha ça va piquer
ans finalement pointé des manques de
marche 4 fois en mode emma c'est place
quatre fois que des marchands puisque
cet endroit ça te loupes l'état evo
pointé plus à faire entre profitable ont
des comptes en plus alou comme un
cerveau puis tout seul les gens de build
up devrait supporter ou cinq a surfé
c'est trippant j'ai vraiment juste le
principe de faïza télévision germain
mais sera ce quelqu un qui moi je suis
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéressait
beaucoup avec une peau qui me passionne
mais je pourrais pas demander ce que je
trouve ça intéressant autant ce qui se
passe en avant ou en arrière de la
caméra fait j'ai tripé faire partie du
show de tv
je serais vraiment les habitants à faire
d'autres choses si jamais une occasion
de prise dans sa tombe peut-être pas
dans l'arrêt d'un saut on s'est jamais
produit
on sut jamais mais tige du possible pour
me donner plus de change dissout par
sabine moi j'avais mon coeur puis elle a
laissé fait que ça c'est vrai que j'ai
vécu
tu peux maintenant parler en mois
connaissance de cause je dois vraiment
jamais j'avais pas agacé j'ai remarqué
c'est dans des shows de même c'est la
vie retire surtout tenté comme dans un
chauffe été filmé tout avec j'ai réalisé
à quel point que ça sert à rien te faire
des scénarios safari je tienne mars
restée pendant l'aventuré j'ai réalisé
que si j'avais un peu moins de destrier
je pense je leur ai vécu un peu mieux
pensez juste vraiment le stress de deux
peintures comme le hockey
qu'est ce qui va se passer que ce qui va
se passer a pas de j'espère comme ok
t'es c'est beau je veux amener ça allait
mais je dirais que j'aime et que c'est
jeter paponi attelly j'aime ce que je
m'en foutais un peu puis je pense et les
gentils qui m'ont fait rire personne de
ce père qui veut nous n'avons comme
contre soi comme si je mange à la table
ronde au plus gros je parle à dieu
cherche il faut mordre au bout pourquoi
je suis sait ce qu'elle fait que c'est
ce qui marche c'est que le monde aime
c'est ce qui fait qu'ils avaient une
meilleure expérience ou city utah ouest
si c'est exact ça c'est la meilleure
école pour apprendre non aux reçus
dernièrement sur le podcast une
spécialiste du stress
fournier du pied le monde qui écoute la
pièce en ce moment il va sortir bientôt
l'épisode tempétueux ce point comme sur
pétulante 3 pers par mois abonnez vous
dans le fond c'est que les affaires que
un des quatre facteurs de stress c'est
le manque de contrôle ou l'impression du
manque de contrôle puis au 10 la
meilleure école pour ce parce que même
stress le même c'était c'est de tout
vouloir contrôler qui contrôle bien je
vais bien beau de crier pendant toute la
semaine pour dire là il faut que ce soit
perçu cette paire solex facilement
perçue à la créatine et si les gens qui
prennent les décisions qui décide des
twists ivala décide que ces porcs telle
personne qui s'en va ce sera quoi telle
personne qui passe à l'aller fait qu
flight des si de rien n'était fait pas
mieux de laisser aller le truc de forêt
le stress que je me mêle
c'est pas moi qui contrôle de toute
façon fait j'ai aucune raison de
stresser a produit ce petit jeu le point
cash compris au début c'est impossible
pendant que tu es dedans au citizen act
est là c'est comme tu es tellement
expliqué que tu veux absolument battre
pour ce qui pour la juste cause puis la
vérité c'est qu'au final ça change rien
parce que ce poteau chivu rat qui va
acter que lui au final je vis mieux
aussi été au début de la saison de
justice est une nation sa maîtresse en
stress permanent échec une boule m'en
fous c'est l'autre commence à vivre je
le suis vraiment on au député comme au
kit c'est ça tapie rapporte à prague
avec les gens comme peu importe si tu es
vraiment y en a comme collation commune
mais c'est que ce colas colas voile est
vraiment qu'ils voient ce ratage et qui
les peuplent ses collègues des
stratégies coutu le droit
thomas stratégique tu seras pas
stratégique c'est la mauvaise stratégie
mais je vois pas parler de la game c'est
aussi une position de faire passer ta
stratégie n'en font pas parler de la
game center ben c'est simple c'est moi
je suis sympa je passe qui a été moi je
suis en fait quand les comme le plus
stratégique ce qui est correct mais
c'est quand même juste pas en cause que
tu es maudit ou que tu es coteaux des
plus qu'un jeu puis que tu peux te parle
du jeu les fois que tu es un gain si
mauvais
maintenant que le mot stratégie toi et
tout relié de manière négative ça c'est
également parce que user de stratégie
initialement mettant dans le monde
entier le 4 4 une situation devant toi
usé d'une stratégie pour réussir à
vaincre la situation l'opposition si
c'est positif mais ce sont exactement
sur ce poste à audi seulement portée
stratégique c'est pas bon c'est pas
grave c'est une stratégie qui était une
mauvaise personne fichée moi j'ai
repensé à un peu au début mais je pense
pas qu'on le voit un show mais c'est moi
au début la première prend élimination
une nation de michael moi je vais gérer
hattab qui comprend pas ça a tellement
été mal géré mais le lui il savait
exactement qui la présentait qu'un point
que s'est fait éliminer ben oui mais là
c'était tout et tout péter
il ya deux faits la maison mix qui sont
quand même un peu intéressant à voir
mick vous mettez dans l'ange bleu c'est
quoi ton nez vêtue clair mat et
comprennent rien
ces mères jeux vidéo au lendemain avec 4
j'ai bien danger parce qu'il veut que la
terrasse et l'europe étaient 1,2 comme
j'avais succès mettons charles qui est
charles débuts critiqués fille très déçu
je m'étais engagé on s'en fout il sera
proposé une nation watch out gimmick qui
vous intéressent pas par tout comme dans
le fond il y avait marjo qui prit la
litterna la photo à luiz ne porte pas au
curry et l'oat les prix là la photo à
charles noeud pap le moins au début je
t'écris sma mais l'itf la balle au chaud
pollue m'intéresserait
c'est lui qui était clairement et j'ai
parlé à lui ya je verrai michael puis
j'ai moins par les samoa clics effectués
c'est simple qui peut s'élever michaël
boch des combats au site il apprécie le
bon c'est un peu tabou et il va plus je
mets des cartes puis j'ai mis mon dans
ma tête que je suis en danger
on sait ce qu'ils veulent je suis moi
j'irais pas là et adeline à se jeter
comme des claques et ce qu'on fait à ce
moment là j'étais stratégique dans un
coin si j'avais proposé une stratégie d'
attaque lui c'est juste ça fait peu
moins qu'à vous une règle non poteau
quelqu'un qui backstab non plus le cpeti
je vis aussi se sent-elle c'est ce qu'on
dit dernièrement je pense que tout le
monde faut qu'on prenne churchill par
rapport à tout ce que vous n'avez pas
vécu mais semaine après semaine aux
dépens des autres c'était un discours de
débat social
il y avait toujours quelque chose
insiste est julie plat façon que tu est
représenté dans l'émission puis après ça
c'était la tricherie barça se taire
est-ce que charles et féministe ou non
plus hésité à chaque semaine y avait une
nouvelle fois c'était comme on s'en
prenait à aller tout le temps une cible
qui est pas fait de quoi comme du monde
sait qu'au final c'est un émission de
télé pour divertir
on fait de vous on fait on a fait de moi
des personnages qui existent comme étant
des personnages fictifs sont basés très
près en proximité avec une vraie
personne mais que les traits sont
exacerbées pour devenir une pure
vraiment un personnage avec
unidimensionnel quasiment être puis à au
final c'est c'est un jeu ont bien qu'on
doit gagner puis tu fais ce que tu peux
faire pour gagner puis ça divertit les
spectateurs puisque non c est ce que
c'est la chose qui traite tous les
enjeux sociaux de la meilleure façon non
c'est pas seul objectif bien on peut
voir venir un peu
êtes vous allé pour être activement
mettons quelle était la réception du
monde qu'est ce que le monde se sont dit
la presse mais d'où potentiel comme là
présentement vivait dans le monde
m'attend et je réponds à sun life en
pause c'est par la gauche a trouvé ses
marques chez les allemands parfait soit
bonne dans ce sens êtes vous un peu
coureurs de mettons toutes les
discussions des beaux arts n'a que eu
par rapport à audi ou patins genre vous
de la pression pour réduire la présence
sur ces nouveaux qu'on était plus proche
de la triche est passée comme moi je
n'ai pas vraiment écrire comme un
dommage je t'ai pas impliqué vraiment
mais c'est sûr qu'ils en avaient après
la réception par rapport tant que
chantier louer on parle et vous avez vu
à l'heure de vérité nous venait
d'apprendre ce qu'est venu apprendre ça
vous avez aucune des eaux qui ne
souscrit pas sa exxon la controverse à
fuir tous le nom cévenol avait vécu
affecté c'est sûr que nous arriver à
l'heure de vérité qu'est ce qui était un
peu plus difficile ça c'est lendemain en
fonte au porte à porte pour tomber dans
ton monde inquiet de voir qui est
vraiment difficile piété et tout le
monde n'était que m'avait larmes au
juste à côté c'est pas gentil ça reste
oui des actions peut pas comme c'est
beau corps et qu'on peut se dire mais à
un point d'arrivée l'heure c'est comme
on s'entend que l'autre et au final leur
garde et youtube sont incapables
maintenant un shoot tolérer le genre il
ya même pas de règles d'un jeu le ya pas
de règles sociales
dans ce sens ça n'est une règle il n'y a
pas de 10 pour avoir accès de
contre ça c'est comme ça mais show s'est
fait éliminer s'est fait éliminer à le
payer les conséquences de son jeu le
centre de sa tricherie à le quitter le
jeu resca mérites d'une enchaînement
gros fait les autres de voir ces petits
soucis qui sait qu est-ce qui est parti
essayez de trouver de temps les méchants
moi ce que j'ai dit je remarque un peu
le ballon est vraiment bien fait et je
voulais pas m'en tiens aux personnes qui
arrivent dans ce groupe si je veux des
fleurs si si si c'est pas ton luth est
une vieille expérience tu vois que ça
donne et c'est sûr que nous
personnellement ça ne veux blesser parce
que c'était berne où fêter c'est ce que
nous ont été plus impliqué que les dents
aussi l'étude la situation effective
c'est sûr c'était pas le fond d'abord
parce que tu habites mais quatre ans
avec ces personnes et affective est
quand même un lien puis tu t'expliques
beaucoup c'est fake c'est sûr que rester
difficiles mais de voir que sur les
réseaux sociaux c'était vraiment refait
pas à toute heure 41 minutes on me fait
un peu justement qu'ils arrêtent
élimination petit nom le gérer on
comprend vous avez comme noda qui merci
mais comme faut qu'on arrive à la façon
c'est pas la façon de fatigue peut dire
c'est pas correct puis si mes adieux à
vridi cité truc du genre et de moby des
autres que si c'est intense il vraiment
melo a fait enfin moi je pense pas que
la tricherie ça a été la chose qui fait
le plus parler
la chose qui fait le plus parler si le
personnage de charles
mouais c'est ce qui fait le plus réagir
plus plus parler à travers apprécié et
il y des gens les gens jugent par
rapport à ce qu'ils voient committee
vous autres vous savez qu est ce qu on
voit il quand même parfois qu'on voit
paul si vous et charline weizman des
fois puis tu vas être pour agrandir
quito leader des fois c'est efficace
ma tv il répète qu'il est leader
maintenant même si c'est ça ça reste un
personnage etc c'est à quel point il ya
du monde qui prennent cette émission le
au sérieux acteurs la salle au tc
démesure et le jeudi
après ça on peut faire des fêtes de jack
layton et des vivres des hôtes charles
qui est son hystérie g que c'est comme
un jeu télé courir mes confuses pour
pour la zone de confort puisque le monde
s'est entraîné sans écouteurs le tamani
je t'ai jamais j'arrive de faire la
course pas d'écouteurs le mma vie
vraiment difficile tu es puis on a tout
fait des jo que l'on ne peut toutes les
deux métiers john faire des jokes une
chose
écrire à quelqu'un aucun bon sens
il faut absolument que ça arriverait
pitié y avait dit il ya eu des temps un
mouvement déjà aux rites charles dont la
tacc après sauter au début des jo qui
sont devenus vraiment méchante
il ya eu un mouvement de genre et le
l'intimidation faut que ça arrête les
réseaux sociaux sera pas de bon sens et
au loin plis urgents un contre-mouvement
des noms les narcisses et qu'il appuie
misogynie méritent ce qui leur arrive
c'est comme si le diagnostic est un
trouble de santé mentale à un bug de vue
dans le travers le prisme de l'émission
petit montage puis semaine le exagère de
tivo trop loin et c'est la force et que
le monde ferait pas ça en écoutant mais
ton doctoral sur grey's anatomy
il verra pas un personnage narcissique
faire genre est lui le pilote écrit à
l'acteur ben stiller 22 tonnes est
malade
c'est clair dans le fond ce qu'ils font
c'est des personnages sont créés fait
que c'est quand tu t'attaques aux
personnages à qui aimait kripo que ses
explications et ses assesseurs c'est
certes un tipi les moments surtout ils
ont été collectés si le ca va plus tu es
bon sinon six mois charles
personnellement je n'ai pas tant
qu'unité fait et qu'est ce que j'y vais
atterrir là j'ai appris à le connaître
par la télé ce site offre pour moi des
proches de lui céder à je connais bien
sûr invités vraiment tpiy ces manchots
clairement à kitimat pressaient pour
full full fait que j'ai pas eu le sait
la chance d'avoir des conversations mais
petit ses amis un show est porteuse
autres et ont eu la chance de passer
plus de temps tire bien sûr passer du
temps avec dans maison mixte où ça s'est
super bien passé c'est juste que sinon
on avait juste pas émis que c'était
comme contenu que ça venait les clubs
s'ils savaient pas où ça vous dit que
charles ce serait mon ami ou votre ami
d'avis mairie
mais tu as tort d'avoir plus connu
charles l'impression que le meneur qui
étaient représentés et fidèle à la
personne écoute chez un gros et vous
avez un biffle mettais mes tongs ipanema
les vivres d'eau disponible la vérité
c'est que moi je ne serai avec une amie
au mix mai mais même si je ne fais avec
avec son tempérament 1 voire plus et
quel genre de que je savais qu'en
sortant daudet nomma le wat
c'est ça les poètes les gens de goût que
j'allais comme vraiment chier avec tes
km/h innov'game maintenant je
m'attendais pas à ce qu'il ya eu de la
chance de l'instant il c'est en
l'écoutant michaud pour le réaliser je
pense que le show on ne paye beau dire
que c'est un show with du montage où il
ya des morceaux qui peuvent être collées
un par dessus l'autre qui donne un
résultat mais ça reste que ce que tu dis
c'est ce que tu dis ceci je me marre dit
plein d'affaires positif sur plein de
monde pique yann et plein de positif à
plein de gens qui ont côtoyé dans la
nature ça reste que nous il nous disait
il ya 10 des enfants de lieux distincts
ce n'est qu'il a dit jeter un vendeur
qui n'utilisent dit que l est insécure
qui voulait pas être son sauveur son
thérapeute msi clarita participation des
rappeurs tu te dis que tu peux de
malades matin mettais tout rien ne dit
que la fille avait besoin de personnel
dirigeant ses effectifs c'est tout des
actions c'est tous des mots tu dis que
c'est ben beau montage mais tu le dit
pareil je disais mais ça change pas le
fait que le groupe chimique il ya plein
d'amis dans la vie piqué il va s'en
sortir de sa charge peu le fait non plus
que je gma est en projet une simulation
puis ce qui se passe à od geste à audi
c'est exactement pour ce que le livre
est fermé on a bien cru nécessaire de
visiter mais ça enlève pour le fait que
même des affaires qui ont pas été cool j
c'est patrice
les liseuses iront peut pas de sauver
une seule c'est plus ce que je pense pas
que la production le montage aux
étudiants étaient contre lui
je pense juste que parce que tout
qu'est-ce qu'on dit qu'il ya des choses
qui auraient pu nous avantager vraiment
puis c'est ça a été mieux simplement
d'idéaux voyons qu'on me sûreté mais
s'ils mettent tout qu'est-ce qu'ils font
du sang c'était dans un sens tu lui dis
comme tu dis ça je dis oui ça risque est
mort pour nous la question et voir les
réseaux sociaux que toi moi ça me fait
de la peine que ces gens vivent ça à
cause que audi c'est tellement plus
steve pour plein de gens c'est à
l'appartement ces différentes rencontres
des gens ait grandi puis souhait c'est
plate que lui son retour était plus
difficile parce que cher que pendant
l'aventuré il ya quand même eu du fun
puis il s'est fait vraiment des potes
oui c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est proche
métier c'est ce que pour nous on est
tellement était proche à ce qu'ils ont
ou bien sont encore le fixie disait pour
nous deux c'est avons une maison tu es
dedans moi j'ai comme la vision de d'or
parce que j'ai regardé tous via call
qu'on a été fait c'est normal que les
gentils mais l'acharnement ça sert à
rien mais moi il y avait des super d'une
nation je répète comme mon chien ça sert
à quoi sert à rien c'est sa perception à
la personne en toi c'est ça votre
changer ce qui a presque eu sa chance
qu'ils ont non non c'est ce vécu m'a dit
que je me dis aussi soit saint justin je
me disais souvent comme si ce n'est pas
la vraie ville
est ce que dans ma vie je faisais tout
en s que j'agirai comme sedan vraie vie
non est-ce qu'en ce moment chez georges
plage comme si j coup de mourir est ce
que c'est vrai tate
mais est-ce que je devrais arrêter
wickham toi votre couche et demain matin
un parti ça va bien dans l'idée fait que
je pense qu'il sera tu mets les réseaux
souci parce que ça ça continue après
pour quelque chose que tu mets ton tu te
fais demandé me ça m'est arrivé je parle
de mon expérience que je sais pas ce que
je te dis pas que les tenues la banque
le toit mais moi ça m'est arrivé on m'a
dit qu'est ce que tu penses du couple de
sans abri qui joignent puis là la
question c'est qu'est ce que tu penses
de leur couple puis je vais donner mon
opinion mais qui
dans la vie est ce que je suis amené à
donner mon opinion en est pas encore
quelque chose que je regrette juste pas
parler sinon exactement mon opinion ne
vaut rien par rapport à leurs copains
d'autres 16e leur affaire sauf que si tu
me demande mon opinion dans un contexte
où je dois de la donner je vais donner
mon opinion c'est que c'est pas vrai
sauf que sauf que jamais dans la vie je
ramenais des réunions de crise même si
ça te regarde pas dans vie de ces
feuilletons dans un contexte de jeu
mettons le schale son opinion de vous
autres étaient négatives dans vie en
général je pas sûr qu'ils donnent le
temps qu'il fait je le connais pas mais
là c'est ça le point c'est qu'on le
connaît pas dans vie on se connaît pas
dans la vie est ce qu'il serait amené à
donner son opinion sur du monde qui la
regardent pas un coq qui le regardent
peau qui rien à voir avec notre
probablement pas fait de commencer à
juger des agissements qui se passe dans
un jeu où est ce qu'on la rose certaines
questions que dans la vie tu prendrais
petit prendrait pas position
c'est tranquille ici j'aime le point
t'amène je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant mais tient mettons je pense
que c'est l'effet de se faire poser des
questions ça arrive et je demande
d'entrevue tonelli confesse tout à fait
ou dans les super et candiac cette
occasion mais où ce que je trouve ce
reproche surtout dans les points de
conversations ces moments surtout sur la
demande qui sont comme des amis puis
sincèrement car personne peut demander
de le faire si ces gens regroupement
pour jean claude tisné moi je trouve moi
je sais pas si c'est là qu'ils méritent
c'est ce qui m'a le plus dérangé surtout
parce que mm
surtout qu'un que moi dans ma tête sans
être prétentieux bâtons jetés comme
crime mais samedi me semble que je fais
pas çi personne personne que j'ai rien
fait qu'on personnes
pinkas que le juge entend sage que le
temps d'introspection phitek est une
marque sa poche mais crime avoir vu les
shows finalement je pense que si je
faisais du sens pis c'est le moment où
est-ce que c'est élever des moutons
passer à table c'est quand je te manquer
ce avec pas de bon sens du terme à ce
qui est écrit comme argument à petit
tous que dans le contexte du jeu c'est
vrai que c'était que le prôner des
valeurs piqué finalement ses actions
notamment de la bonne humeur c'est ça le
point c'est ça je pense que moi c'est
sur ça que j'accroche le plus c'est
d'être dans le contexte du jeu ce que la
prenais des valeurs qui étaient passés
agissements mais la prémisse dans le
contexte du jeu
moi je pense qu'il ultra importante à
garder en tête le temps tout le temps
tout le temps tout le déficit mais là le
problème c'est que le nom ton nom et le
même paysage plutôt un résultat
d'instagram parce que tout le monde peut
venir directement démence de ce que tu
as fait dans le contexte du jeu c'est
vrai mais c'était blessant au processus
même si le temps d'en discuter et je
vous dis un peu ce que j'en pense que je
vous dit comment je me suis senti entre
eux mais c'est sûr de tout à fait qu on
prend ça change pas le fait que mène ça
vaut pas la peine d'être des personnes
et personne qui tue personne et c'est
bon t'es tu prends les bacs mais tu es
fou de comprendre que dans vie on ne te
fait des choses qu'on est pas fier je
suis toujours en fait
c'est là faut qu'on comprenne qu'il y
ait des caméras pickel toutes les choses
passent marketing qui nous écoutent le
penser à la mac ou est-ce que vous êtes
le moins fier de vous autres c'est vous
qui avez une caméra qui filmait sur le
québec au complet le révulse évidemment
genre on serait tous dans une
institution mardi exactement ce fait des
essais de phase i avec gameiro dkg
l'histoire moi il y en a plein qui me
vient des décors ou que s'il y avait une
caméra là cette fois le j'adore ça je me
serais fait vous êtes quoi j'étais en
fait 100 % se montre aux étapes sauf moi
vous encourager ces risques est
justement parce qu'il y en ait qui
paraissent par bien pianais qui sort de
l'eau picom c'est plus rough le piquer
le public les a moins mais il n'a pas
passé pénal à l'appui c'est quand même
quand même bon game bal de neige va la
marotte evry je sais pas comment je vais
très présente et juste après moi le
public comme percevoir pigot je vois pas
des choses que je me dis en plus de ce
temps contexte difficile que tu sais pas
nécessairement exactement comment tu vas
réagi parce que t'es jamais vu sur le
thé d'être isolé d'être compté quelques
secondes que tu connais pas ses potes
c'est pas comme à toi même tu va agir le
temps il y en a qui sont arrivés leur
moi je connais du monde personnellement
les grosses foules confiance la loi puis
arrive la pile cause complète dans
l'histoire du j'aime j'aime c'est juste
c'est moi si je me dis crème d'arrivée
le ne pas savoir exactement comment
gérer mes émotions comment je vais
réagir comment je vais travailler avec
le monde puis de risque et qu'il est
sorti de l'oeuf de détester par les
cadets au complet
je savais ce que je trouve pas le fan de
savatan j'écoute d'été des émissions
comme un peu phrase cote le genre et
j'écoute sopi a maintenant la file
si l'afrique est comme un petit gars
comme une rédemption le théâtre c'est
parfait c'est normal que étant des
chaussées comme en vrai que le monde
sait ils deviennent attaché à toi pour
une certaine raison et puis c'est ça que
je trouve drôle c'est parce que je
regarde on y ont été castés pour être
différent fait c'est sûr et certain
qu'ils vont avoir un peu plus de
caractère
puis normalement la 5e puis caractère
comme homme alors aller petit à petit
mais c'est son caractère 3 cm qui elle
même si moi je plus soft et est ce que
j'aurais fait pour pina déjà qu'en fait
comme si jamais rien t'es trop sale
gosse paca pire que ce n'est jamais
gagné
il va toujours avortés vous axé sur vous
vous avez des commentaires d'art est
aussi c'est sûr à moins que je me trompe
des personnes que vous écris de là j'ai
vraiment saito adam j en ai vu un g8 g8
est très bon un message que j'ai vu très
dominant bien qu'ils aient vu qu'ils
faisaient
t'as pas de respect envers le public
fuck you know jack mais je sais qu'on
peut facilement passer par le stade
pourquoi
mais non on est vraiment chanceux ouvrir
piste une série mercy tout le monde
parce que ça aurait pu le tuer
pissarides à calais moi je trouve tes
seins qui m'a vraiment fait plaisir
c'est que ma mère si c'était une femme
qui était plus âgé videmment puis elle a
dit c'est pas t'expliquer apprend par
les crises de caunes pour les autres a
ajouté m la ponctuation le souhait maman
tu senti mieux
ouais bon sa maison non mais manger
écrit justement puis j'ai dit mais merci
parce que c'est vrai que chez papa j'ai
beau me fait que je m'étais apprécié
avec ma compagne de mouss et on va se
donner de l'amour tu apprends à paris
puis au pire toujours je finis puis j'ai
pu déchiffrer ces faits que ça va aller
mieux oui la quantité passante et la vie
chacun sait que je parle de mes émotions
l'oeil je vais publier je te dis je veux
capable d'exploits est capable pouvait
bien julie en fait une compilation de ce
challenge c'est bon ça c'est nickel je
dirais c'est de toute beauté
si à l'heure de vérité il ya tant
d'enfants une une des choses qui vous a
fait que vous êtes restés ouverts eventi
le plus par saison c'était vraiment
comme justement quand il ya eu la
tricherie tous d'affaires lopy et loana
as mais avoue par les plats à s'excuser
à profusion le plat s'excuse pas
s'excuser à dame chez nous on l'écouté
puisque c'est comme ça là aussi
contribué au fait qu'ils gangs fait
comme une excuse le ca voltz et camille
ont gagné au décès quand yvon payne
mais c'est sûr savez à savait déjà
excusé pour être contente de l'avant ses
excuses pour moi je souhaite le meilleur
à 10 h as je voulais dire qu'est ce
qu'il y avait malgré tout cas pas ce que
tu fais haut d une fois puis les choses
que tu vois mais la seule chose c'est
l'heure de la vérité aux motards vérité
c'est ce qui s'est passé mais elles
aussi me dénoncer les excuses puis j'ai
fait je prends tes excuses c'est sûr tu
t'es bon quelqu'un c'est la jolie pièce
qu c'est fini et merci je prends tes
excuses piste et ça ça va être beau au
fait qu'est je pense qu'ils et oui c'est
ça a contribué métier dans un sens est
ce qu'on voulait que ça nous arrive des
choses que omar arrivé moi je trouve
mais non et pourrait j'apprécie ses
excuses puis yasi pourrait aller bien ça
laisse pas bien paru aussi sa femme sait
comment je m'excuse pitt a tout d'abord
puis je pense que oui ce qui m'anime m
je n'excuse correctifs en passant par
l'aide à votre condo le phénomène
canadien avait gagné on était sur un
nuage on est encore d'ailleurs si je
pense que cette offre est arrivée la
goutte de marquer mais je suis quand
même contente parce que moi pour ma part
je lui dis dans une colle des missions t
c'est sur le fait qu'il aurait quitté
par elle-même c'était un bon step voté
pour nous aussi au moment de la touriste
suprême c'était un bon steak mais
j'avais comme moi personnage avait pas
encore eu lieu et j'ai foiré je m'excuse
c'est pile à l'heure de vérité j'en ai
eu
québec on t'aime c'est parfait c'est
correct parce qu'elle m'a fait tout le
monde fait des erreurs moi même je dis
jamais tu es tu fais erreur on me
reprochait des trucs que je m'excusais
je laisse mes fait je pense que c'est
juste important dans les gares et je
dirige les marquis machette
on pense à autre chose fait que j'ai
bien apprécié c'est d'abord des looks
gérant de prendre le chip de ddt action
c'est ce dont il souhaite que du bon la
cité lot ils nous écoutent cette manche
avec la spéciale je suis comme que
hyundai est parfait j'ai des points de
rançonner et puis tu joues mais sur
l'année à bassa
c'est ça reste que ces situations de jeu
mais les deux on leur souhaite vraiment
dit à irin nous on était impliqué c'est
ben beau que ça nous implique nous mais
ça reste la fin de journée ou début juin
on sait que ça va rester la même chose
pythie comment on répète il souhaite pas
tout la reine des cimes et ont
l'expérience leur fait avoir une
introspection pu apprendre aux enfants
c'est l'excellent milieu grundy ça pour
ça c'est seul but lance un bonjour moi
je serais rentré d'un calcul à l'heure
de vérité en disant genre ça va être
soft le tout le monde mesure qui
s'aiment mais parce que la finale soit
les trois coupes c'est parce que ces
gens là l'heure de vérité je te laisse
libre ce qui s'est dit
pinon mais je pensais pourtant tout le
monde savait si les bonnes choses mais
ça reste quand même ça c'est il ya des
choses qui était dit qu'ils étaient
moins respectueuse mais quand même tout
le monde sait apporter son point c'est
bon aussi t on d'emblée des questions
partir des enfants qui avait été opérée
que mon avis je l'écouté pas d'accord
que qui était de ce matin
par exemple dans mes propos correct mais
je ne sais quoi et je fais me rappeler
qu est-ce qu est-ce qui est il ou elle
attache les pattos date je peux les
sabots mais pas progressé jusqu'à des
fois c'était on n'a pas besoin de secret
après des fois sa sérénité qu'on est
tellement nos émotions proche de nous
qu'ils ont réalisés pas ça serait plus
le monde embarque été c'est facilement
plus été le tkc mieux tous plus stylé
prix c'est normal c'est des vraies
émotions fait que mais moi dans mon
statut dans ma vie j'aimerais que cela
soit genre tout le show ça a été les
deux semaines qui finissent n'est ce pas
même un show où le thé l'humidité est
possible que tout soit beau tout avance
toute la machinerie fait mais la femme
maintenant la façon que toi te ramener
ton points en étant ultra cannes poser
c'est aussi une façon tout à fait
légitime de régler un conflit peut
importe la grande la magnitude de ce
conflit
oui d'élever le ton ça être personne
jamais j'ai piqué c'est pour ça que j'ai
déboîté pas besoin de crier jusque été
ça va s'avancer mais tout le monde vers
leur dévotion différemment je pose alors
un ennemi bravo tout genre comme ça
c'est pas tout le monde que je dois même
c'est correct et tu dois te lève le ton
ont piqué ses sapins aujourd'hui nous on
est tous différent fait que vos
collègues non mais t'es juste à cri
lutte étape avant le match et que ce
marché n'est pas toshiba de batteries
casas aimé inscrire merci aux gars des
fois je connais pas tu m'as ressenti
comme un plus gentil ça il fait de la
peine facilement ces genres jimmy ajouté
seront prises puis je trouver
satisfaction la séquence de jamis tout
jamais j ai pas te pleurer
cain dans quinquis rien qu'un taux de
charge vous en voyez vous engagez vous
qui vous l'avez lever le ton aux
assesseurs bâtisse je trouve intéressant
secte et comme tu dis tantôt - moi je
pilais menions s'entendaient pas sur les
vérités bros autant je me savais que
charles c'est la situation des douches à
sa lèvre déçu j'étais peu surpris mais
je pense que dans des villes tester en
vrai que c'est comme le monde sont venus
télé le monde et préparez vous au final
vous avez pas eu tant de temps à
réfléchir à toutes les situations le
team et le long qui sont fait éliminer
semaine 6 le fait que depuis ce même si
son lob tabarnak que je veux vidéo si on
arrive près le monde arrive armé de ses
pistes ça reste que c'est un long
tournage les montants fatigue et la
mauritanie
c'est lourd le témoin je pense que vous
n'avez pas dormi de la nuit que c'est ce
qui est des gros sujets qu'il se dégage
en touche et on peut pas nier le fait
que senna d amener des très gros point
noir est aussi margerie puis je faisais
je pense que ce qui est dit comme je
l'aï dit dans l'émission ce qui n' a dit
hrw est très difficile à des prix selon
moi nadir prix et les coiffeuses et
après tout le monde marc son bateau le
lançant ce qui est le prix l'équipe au
complet puis à les écrire il pas ce que
c'est et je pense que beaucoup de monde
pensait les mêmes choses qu'elle met
tout le monde en ce moment et se serait
fait écrire par des millions de
personnes de différents bords du pont
mais en même temps si ces mêmes n'a dès
lors elle le dit qu'elle a évoqués
victime un peu de commentaires du petit
d'homophobie toupie jeudi je pense que
de l'adisq l année comme point c'était
très valable quinquennat dedic et qu'il
faut pas que marjo sorte la carte là la
carte d'homosexualité toujours pour
justifier tout ce qu'elle fait bercy
vérité parce que krim josé mon marge
aussi quelqu'un qui j'ai une excellente
relation à la maison mix avec no you see
pour ce qui en est on voit josek marc
jolivet semaine huit ou neuf le camp des
cinq à sept reprises en civil nous
espionner love game je parlais pas de
lag et moi je parraine marjo match homme
qui a fait de même c'est juste savoir ce
qui se passe
fake c'est juste ce petit jeu et écrire
mais il s'en est passé des affaires dans
sa tête elle c'est correct mais c'est
juste d'essayer de comprendre comment
thann et en titane est arrivé le pis je
pense que nadie le très bien ben ouais
mais ça reste que cet artiste est risqué
comme ce genre mais si ça puis elle est
vraiment me fait mais ça reste que oui
adar feu de l'action ce test est intense
n'a laissé levé l élever le ton un peu
marge aussi à le quitter la pièce à
pleurer sexistes l atmosphère très
lourde mais moi je suis satisfait quand
même de ce qui a été dit pillés
un gilet mon chapeau mottet en écoutant
chaud j'ai pas eu l'impression que
mettons le couple cintio margerie et est
perçu différemment où était jugée plus
négativement à cause que c'est un couple
homosexuel peut pas tout j'ai jamais eu
cette impression très content c'est tout
le monde est content pour la première
fois la barre pour m non mais c'est
juste getty metz et mettons tout le
monde s'entend c'est alain terme ben on
le sait jamais été une question de tubes
sait jamais une question d'homophobie de
sortir de sortir cette carte le c'est
vrai que chaque accès à cette situation
là parce que ça existe l'homophobie
hausse entamée dans ces situations là ça
ne s'applique pas aux sites atx et le
fait qu'elle soit en couple avec cynthia
juste fille pod team et on traverse t
imagines que cynthia c'est un autre
gueule et tu déclares adia qui a ri une
journée a été montée date 7 pour tous
jusqu'à fin par un voyage avec un autre
gars frentzen augure ajoute un art vient
la situation lama nazih je croix
potencée couples eux aussi parce que je
tricote des deux filles ces croix
potencée concourès pascal s'est
effectivement le point bon de dire que
c'est au tce de dire ça de tenir ce rôle
a considéré que ce sujet est tellement
sensible pour toutes les raisons du
monde qui sont extrêmement légitime par
l'histoire de la société occidentale ans
que l'on vit le type il faut le dire à
culmont par le sommet mais ça c'est
plick et plock à sa clique près ça
s'applique pas si je devais comme on
repense pas nous aimer aussi que 10
qu'idiot super at il n'y a pas de
règlement à l'amour est tu peux faire ce
que tu veux que fréquentable à ses 5000
pour sans abri mais il ya un bon et
quand même garant des actions exactement
il ya moyen de s'y rendre si tu peux
faire ce que tu veux mais soit on est
avec les gens qui sont concernés dit les
choses qui se passe réellement
puis il faut juste que se recueillir
article
le csfa avait mis mon argent au début de
l'émission sur sweet loudéac et le
sachiez semaine d action pour vrai c'est
en parlant des mois j'ai trouvé ça quand
même beau de voir des copeaux c'est qui
qui était plus ensemble c'est qu'ils
décident les ans c'est très rare qu'on
voit ce parce que je trouvais que
c'était beau à voir ce aussi parce qu'il
pousse mans c'est les gens qui ont comme
le courage de faire ôter je me
retrouvais notes afin que des fois des
fois il y avait jean le genre de
discours de beloeil aurait dû rester
avec un test car fame c'est comme tu
peux pas forcer non plus non mais des
fois c'est comme elle la loyauté puis le
intel aurait dû rester avec un tel
jusqu'à la fin même si un show qui prône
l'amour maintenant parce que c'est cela
baraki d'avancé tout le temps puis on
prendra mon premier amour mais la manne
issue fils pas avec quelqu'un tu reste
pas avec sa voix dix minutes par jour
manute moyens qu'ils puissent développer
des sentiments
marjo a peut-être pas été de la plus
grande cloche ou le tai chi arrimer ton
mais qu'elle le fait que les ricains à
saly aucun problème latent annoncé qu'un
seul et c'est juste ce qu'il faut dire
ce qui est c'est plein de aussi le fait
que ce qu'enseigne quelqu'un c'est pas
grave le fait qu'ils soient homosexuels
c'est pas grave quand mais c'est comment
tu te prends comme c'est presque
toujours directement exactement puis
c'est juste ce que nous a dit je pense
voulait amener pis si ce que mr jouant
peut-être imputé à comprendre
c'est ce qu'écrit flammèches finalement
quand on y repense de la grée en fait
c'est sacré quelque chose c'est une
bonne discussion - live
l'heure de vérité ça prend ça prend du
courage quand même pour des sujets aussi
sensibles de celui dit puis j'accepte
pop qui sortent cet argument à l'eau
parce que parce que ça s'applique pas
ici
ouais ça sachant qu'il va manger comme
sachant que sur toute l'année ici c'est
un peu sa liste est c'est la file kiki
comment je faisais kikie ahou caennais
des messages dépit des pouvoirs de
dietrich qu'une femme blackfeet et c'est
elle qui dit khan est un message le pied
tellement fier de ce bijou jeu très
inspiré par tous est vraiment affecté
nadir des trains aussi a été l'avant a
dit aussi comme quoi que à respecter
marjo de s'afficher avec une femme de le
phare atterri tout sur wii ça prend des
bains ya les messieurs mais ça reste que
une certaine manière de faire tout est
dans la manière ce serait grâce à ses
batteries
c'est quoi qui s'en vient pour voir ce
que vous avez pensé à votre futur sera
prochainement aller rouler sur l'a15 en
direction
c'est un kama bay la famille mais là
c'est ce que ce oui en ce moment
j'habite a vécu alors j louis et à mais
sinon je constate travaille et j'aime
boutique de linge pour enfants fait que
je construis ça et je trouve c'est
surtout travail cette semaine qu'on va
travailler la terre une boutique de
linge prend fin avec massages passé
ceballos des vêtements usagés des 0 à 12
ans
des vêtements usagés qui fait que
n'at-on que turquie qui ont des enfants
qui ont fini d'avoir des enfants cette
grandeur le talent et le chili et on
avait un petit au début mais on s'est
dit qu'on allait vraiment ali et type
avec des fonctions québécois qui aux
autres cvc inclus puis que nos pétrier
parce que des fois de cession plus tard
c'est fait on voulait vraiment que ce
soit lavé puis effectué depuis on
choisira qu'est-ce qu'on ait besoin de
ces dans le 50 ans un peu importe pierre
poisson fait son nid chaque deux
semaines on est des affichages puis
cesser ou si c'est en ligne puis
tellement peur est à gatineau d'enfants
et masse osseuse c'est tout le magasin
puis se démarquant du ton nom a
également présenté entrepreneurs hockey
entre mais celle ci est oui
puis l'heure dans le fond le tueur
retourne au travail j'imagine fera
d'abord amener ça va amener beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de monde
j'en parlais pas trop trop pendant ce
jour parce que je m'essaie et m'asseoir
plus money to sagesse a pu prouver qu
dit c'est un fait ça c'est pas que ça
devienne trop bas on veut certainement
pas engager de la business
je me disais je vais attendre et revenez
pour elle au site a lieu à une enfant
aussi tu as une famille a comme quand
même gérer le monde parlait engage trois
autres mélodies parce que c'est toi tu
vas au délai ce moment qu'ils aient
décidé de l'attaquer mais le ont leurs
propres gens parlent un peu plus le ton
il rappelle que le souci et non je vais
je me promène jamais choix et on est sur
facebook puis sur instagram si ce qui
n'a pas bien fermé témoin actif parce
que sur facebook on n'a plus de famille
qui s'est vu que le monde achète c'est
parfait ça tu vas avoir une page à 1000
abonnés sur facebook savent alors plus
que 30 milles sur instagram en date
exactement ce qu'on est vraiment l'être
on l'aimé beaucoup de richesses au but
les familles utilisent beaucoup plus
facebook
ces semences et une mère de famille que
nous contacter mme allende d'envoyer un
message facebook s'est rappelé à ces
âges et russie dès que son gers pas mal
plus petit je commence à plus d'en
parler ouvertement menti pour ramener à
audi moi ce n'est pas vraiment ma
compagnie je savais déjà que ça
fonctionne et je vivais tu fais bien
exclusivement de ce match là soit vous
payez des salaires des salaires des
salaires
oui puits par des boues si je suis
encore là dans ce scoop
aude et puis sachez cd contrefaits que
pour moi cette fois dans quelque chose
avec mon ordi puis que je fais quand
même dans ses puits que c'était familial
fait que pour moi c'est ça fonctionne et
puis je souhaite comme si je veux
vraiment aller trouver quelqu'un que
j'avais pour trouver quelqu'un c'est pas
grave je suis content du trophée que je
conserve par survie et ce fait qu'il
était passionné par les oiseaux du
littoral le contraire adamo qui talea
audible que jésus grosbill de foncer
dans un ego qui s'appelait gros béglé
planes a platement gros big tout le
monde s'y met à s'appeler gros becs
plomb s'appelait grobet grobet what you
grow bon groupe de gars plein mais fait
à mon jeune âge je suis dans un groupe
d'arabes l'enfer même quand on s'appelle
du groupe et qui risquent la faillite
est groupe s'appelait gros bon sens
groupe d ça plaît grosbill non la plus
facile vous appelez sono le surnom qui
donnait au bois comme tu es quand tu as
pélican bégoux gros c'est lui le monde
gros bug qui s'appelait grauby plat mais
tout le monde que les garçons on s'est
mis à s'appeler gros béjart et mènent
grand bec placé sur caméra palin s'est
longtemps plaint d'occupation notamment
s'appelle groupe bic depuis son band
s'appelle gros big bang de business
produite
j'essaye à chaque boutique déjà de
découvrement médiévale cette année comme
alors la vérité ya quatre tours de la
maison des gueux les ados partie du
temps ce convoi 46 appareils de la
preuve c'est qu'ils trouvent sur rov
parce qu'on peu d'activités genou lui
venait d'arriver la maison des groupies
c'est ce qui me disait tu sais ce qui
réduit est reparti à la baisse à une
autre livre en partie puisque le verbe
du monseigneur puis on parlait avec des
bons mots avec un thème médiéval puis ça
passait bien dans la maison des gars qui
te dis presque parce qu'il n'a pas
d'activité c'est carrément la faune ses
tout débuts ici fiq lausanne c'est
devenu la maison d'aigus jusqu'à la fin
de l'aventuré sauter la fin kiev jimmy
viennent la maison déguste retour à la
vie des tic à qui c'est sûr que c'est
pas un gars qui triment médiévale 10 à
12 ans c'est ce qu'annonce et son
calendrier lui que le plus fait
remarquer ccsf système plus juste tempo
fâcher personne quand on faisait pas ce
genre pour faire pitié ou non parce que
c'était moi mes moments préférés si
karadzic standard histoire mon seigneur
du temps du mal au chamanisme
gfk tablait pompiers n'ont cessé ces
renouvellements de contrats en partie sa
fille le père bourgeois donjons dragons
sur cette table aussi stevie g en avoir
environ 100 segments de la vie
quotidienne je pense à soir dans
l'émission est fait kg barre d'écouté
c'est parce que c'est une machine ni
tellement bon lit s'exprime tellement
bien il a une oblique quand même un
sérieux mais je pense à soi pour revenir
à la question ont interdit ou limite a
répondu des très bons moyens le djia est
bâtie pour répondre au moment de nous le
sait tout le monde veut savoir les
condos lab la cessoie kanouté qu'on a
une chance des xi près on z et nagera ni
le 200 parce que les deux hommes
n'étaient pas ensemble clairement oui
c'est ça la minute qu'elle conduit
presque vous savez une date de livraison
par crainte nombreux meetings cette
semaine avec les crises fête ses 15 ans
qu'on dise taille de hits mais c'est sa
fille julie fait que le plan c'est
vraiment des ménages en condos difficile
mais ça s'arrête une première daudet le
sait ça se passe puis je vous le
souhaite absolument pas vraiment et pour
répondre et
jeudi on disait beaucoup m'ont qui ne
posera puis avez vous demandé
elle ne peut pas demander mais ajout de
parts vous pensez à peut-être dit gâtés
foutez vous repensé à ce petit pays
pauvre et on lui donne des réponses à
une chose c'est non plus pas non plus
faire plaisir aux oreilles des gens
c'est non parce que non pour vrai on est
des deux personnes qui voient loin
qu'ils pensent positif billets ça se
reflète beaucoup des relations fait que
et eon advienne que pourra mais sérieux
le condo on y pense on note dès que
c'est possible on il veut bien
on imaginerait mambou futur ensemble on
est content de mon côté moi mais je
retourne travailler en 2021 fait que je
prends une le reste du mois décembre off
mais dès que 2021 l'arrivée je me
remette label chase puis on va retourner
travailler puis à pont de tous et sur le
niveau de ses instincts grammont visa
pour des collaborations qui vont être
ici juste un doute je suis bien ouverts
j'adore promouvoir des produits qui vont
intéresser je suppose c'est que ça les
petits que je vende des autos que je
vende des bains ou princes flanqué sur
dix c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
c'est en fait plaisir de véhicules et
aux jeunes
c'est toi qui est arrivé avec l'eag la
terminologie de sauce mêmes chercheurs
que oui parce que nous autres au
secondaire on parle sûr on dit souvent
les mêmes enfants en même temps mais
aussi au secondaire on utilisait le
terme chausse à toutes les sauces la
natation puis qu'inquiets mettant en
faisant un entraînement qui était
vraiment d'école st on disait tout le
temps dans son soutien mais ton ironique
il ya une situation de marque renault
est déjà sûre c'est parce que renault on
mangeait avec kaka ne connaissait le nom
au des graisses non non non c'était pas
méchant de masseube ok genre oh eh bien
on avait 12 1 en classe économie
il revient bredouille dalphond lille 3-1
pluie qui est comme de l'argent mon
frère d'ange et montfrin tenté comme les
trois ans plus jeune mais jean reno
secondaire soleil était encore utilisé
la technologie sauce nous on était sûr
ça venait de renoncer parce que là on en
parle au secondaire avec lui type et
qu'on était sûr que lui qui avait mené
sur l'album et laurier l'allemagne nous
a dit que c'était toi qui as comme été
utilisées a vraiment littéralement de
toutes les façons une soirée dans un
parti depuis mouvement là bas j'avais
créé adam jones a pas de sens c'est je
me rappelle plus
je pense que c'était quelqu'un dit à
jamie dimon a sorti tel est le sens
jimmy qui french des cibles quelqu'un
l'a perdue à un moment
la même soirée n'a dervier pas
maintenant et faites à ces gens là
soient rejetés lors d'une sortie est ce
que voulait dire ces gens s'expriment
avec cédric evain comme quelqu'un amène
une expression dans l'histoire tout le
monde c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
sonne creux que j'utilisais dans la vie
de tous les jours à 20 puis ça fait
longtemps que je sais pas trop pourquoi
mais tu sais ce qui se dit gg années
seulement je pense que sa sortie
probable pas vraiment hâte de lire ses
mails avec noémie stacy j'étais
littéralement dans la sauce même
trop chaud comme moi je te garde
j'ai réfléchi la sauce amont goupillé
aparté un bon jeu renault qui s'est
officiellement renault qui a pris ce
terme ne puis que l'e mail est attribuée
en étant le solde base parce que je
crois qu'elle cachait la sauce j'avais
toujours des imprévus
j'avais toujours des idées qu'on fait ça
fait huit ans qu'il se soit on a vingt
salles en entrevue plus rien des gamins
de sasbach sa partie de la marge aux
halles le pnue siens mais il a fait
appel à la taxe aurait vraiment fait que
de levier montchamp d'un je suis dans
sauce réduit dans son gréement ces
malades nc j'ai tellement ri qu'on
disait savent la crise en seconde
appelée saga toy un chandail que le
monde c'est sûr que plein maintenant de
fiqh nous trouver caveau secondaire le
taux de cette année qu'en fait voyons
pas fait attendre au goût du mois les
gars qui écrit des articles sur toutes
les émissions de tv le droit que les
classiques sur la sauce le genre avec
audi le piton toutes les expériences
toutes les manières qui vous avec jean
pierre décliné tout et on verra
c'est le goût du monde sur l'assaut qui
j'en doute on s'envoyait ce genre dans
le nouvion hudson secondes à jouer le
jeu
j'adore l'expression la gratte tout à
quelqu'un qui grattent st catharines top
la gratte le au final ça a duré comme
deux à trois semaines maintenant les
deux trois premières semaines ou est-ce
que dumont qui au final comme découvre
des personnes toi tu as parlé à trois
personnes se sont déjà fait les ongles
par noémie gens qui devraient moins
pâtir
cet agent sequana directionnelle
avec accents de brûlot moi j'avais fait
gagner était ici le jeu capable de dire
ce mot le chili
ces crimes à penser qu'ils vont rester
maintenant j'ai mes amis que chez qui on
restait pour toute la vie parce qu'on
avait quelque chose ensemble que
personne d'autre qu'on prend maintenant
le puy 28 je les vois pas caché que ça
va être pour tout le temps c'est qu'ils
vous autres qui va rester dans votre
ville que vous savez déjà
et moi je reste ici sinon il ya une pige
ilian qu'on aime vraiment vraiment
beaucoup et pendant l'aventuré comme on
on a vécu pas mal de trucs singh l'a
fait qui est ce vraiment vraiment
beaucoup pour les autres ici c'est un
défi que je m'entends bien aimé pourrait
comme les 3g une mairie le jitem
vraiment vraiment vraiment couper sinon
et jimmy évidemment parce que c'est avec
ce type tout seul et n'a des pâtes mais
damage super sic mais vous où mme
et on va vous faire aimer ce nom et
sigean les jeunes couples
moi je rajouterais à ce genou oui
j'oubliais ce que la médecine on aura
nos pauvres et moi j'ai vraiment j'ai
vécu trois semaines avec qui tu es
c'était hamas pour réaliser à quel point
que
ces grands parce que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup pleuré pour angie d'ailleurs
c'est ce que j'ai le plus public c'est
pour l'élimination des opm pourrais-je
et risque c'est plus vieux que moi il
est tout les toutes les raisons de
peut-être pas autant mais ces gens en
plus qui sait de moins de vingt trois
anglais richard tse fake mais trop page
le super super smash agi comme mentor à
mon égard moi je trouve ce malade
sûrement il fallait bien qu'on vous
pleins de connaissances y est contenu il
fera jaser fait qu'ici ce truc que j'ai
essayé de passer des moments avec quand
ce sera possible d hugo le cse je lis
aussi je leur mets tout cas on attend
c'est sûr que du monde que vous avez
arrêté
merci des minimes 1 comme savoir garder
votre temps à séville on peut y croire
fait 35 ans s'amuse
oui merci l'alien vous remercier guillon
vous à 9 h à ria